just a few weeks ago I attempted to
ditch my Mac by switching to the newest
iPad with the latest software and the
bridge procured I came into it trying to
find an answer to the question so many
of you asked can I finally just have one
device or the other common question
should I buy a MacBook Air or an iPad
the experience was better than expected
but after about a week the answer was no
and it depends but now that I got my
hands on Apple's new magic keyboard
which I still think is really
ridiculously priced the answer now is
yes and I no longer feel like I need my
basic compact MacBook and I think most
of you don't either now there are still
a few downsides which I'll cover in just
a bit but first let me explain why I'm
Way happier this time around and as much
as I hate to say it I think Apple's
crazy priced keyboard is worth it first
off one thing that I've really liked
about using the iPad pro as a laptop
replacement was the touch screen I never
thought that I would want a touch screen
on a macbook but now I do because
sometimes it is just quicker or better
than using a trackpad and with Apple's
new magic keyboard it's even better I
honestly wasn't expecting the floating
design to matter that much but it
surprised me the iPad is closer to you
which makes the 11 inch screen size seem
bigger and it makes using the navigation
bar
much more comfortable one thing I kept
trying to do a few weeks ago was reach
down for a trackpad but this time around
it is actually there and can I just say
that it is shockingly good I've used a
ton of trackpads over the years and even
though it's not a force touch trackpad
it is one of the best that I've used I
don't know what they did but it is not a
diving board design like most Windows
laptops so you haven't even feel
wherever you click now it is small so
that's like a bit to get used to but it
is super accurate for clicking tapping
and all of the gestures the Apple
supports which seems like pretty much
everything I do on my macbook if you
have an older macbook that uses a diving
board trackpad this one is actually
better now another thing that surprised
me is how I naturally just started using
both attract pad and the touchscreen and
interchanging between them depending on
what is faster and feels
natural yes I do have to admit that you
when those guys were right touchscreens
are definitely worth it for laptops now
probably my biggest issue with using the
iPad before was the keyboard none of
them are really that great and I didn't
expect the magic keyboard to be great
either but I was wrong
the keys feel fantastic I was skeptical
that they were gonna use the same
switches as in the new MacBooks but it
does seem like they are the backlighting
looks great and unlike the bridge
keyboard my fingers don't feel cramped
and don't hurt after a two-hour typing
session they feel very stable with a
perfect amount of feedback and having
that extra port for charging is great as
I was writing this review I went back
and forth between my Mac Pros keyboard
and this iPad case actually feels better
due to the extra feedback now I know
that I'm sounding like a major fanboy
and trust me I do have some complaints
and I'm still not happy about how much
Apple is charging but I am just so
surprised about how well it works as we
were waiting for the keyboard to come in
I watched mkbhd s review and some of his
complaints really worried me and even
though I'm a major laptop fan like he is
I have to say that I don't agree with
some of his points I was worried about
the angle of just ability being limited
but I never actually felt like I wanted
it to tilt more even when I was on my
lap speaking of that he mentioned that
it's off balance since the iPad is
floating and that is true it's not as
good as a MacBook but I used it on my
lap for over an hour and a half and it
works surprisingly well
way better than any other keyboard case
that we've tested I was also worried
about the weight and the thickness as he
mentioned but as I took it around with
me on the go I didn't find that it was
really that bad it was fairly similar to
other options and more comfortable than
lugging around the new MacBook Air at
least with the 11 inch version now
here's a couple complaints that still
aren't great if you're somebody that
does a lot of typing like I do when
you're trying to erase a sentence it
still takes forever as the cursor
doesn't speed up but with that said
since we now have a trackpad in some
apps you can quickly select text and
just delete it like you can on a Mac
which was one of my biggest complaints
moving to an iPad now I said some apps
because Google Docs which I use the most
doesn't
corta just yet but hopefully they will
update it soon another issue is that
some apps don't support split view as
mkbhd mentioned using zoom and trying to
take notes doesn't work that well
because it doesn't allow you to use that
but thankfully you could still have an
app open in the slide over menu so you
can take notes but the size of it is
smaller so there are still down sights
to using an iPad as a macbook
replacement but with a new great
keyboard there are now way more up
sights to getting an iPad instead of a
MacBook Air and my biggest reason for
sticking with the air is now gone
because of that I am no longer gonna be
taken around my Mac unless I need Final
Cut Pro the iPad is just way more
capable overall and more flexible and
for all of you trying to decide between
buying a new MacBook Air or an iPad pro
go for the iPad as long as you're gonna
be buying this really stupidly over
expensive case I think you're gonna be
very happy with it
as long as you can forget how much you
paid now I don't want to repeat my talks
on apps gaming CPU and graphics
performance battery life fan noise
speakers display quality and much more
since all of those things I covered in
my last video they're still super valid
so if you haven't seen it yet click
right over there if you want to see more
honest tech videos click that circle
above to subscribe and make sure you
guys enable those notifications if you
guys have any comments or questions let
me know down below this van Max and I'll
catch you in the next video
[Music]